it makes you think about life and living
it to the fullest and
stop procrastinating so thank you
because you die too soon let me tell you
that's the message i'm going to take the
test next week
pass it with flying comments
in the film shatner plays a retired nasa
test pilot who loses his driver's
license
and is forced to take public
transportation but don't feel too sorry
for him
unlike in real life he finds love on the
bus
you don't look like a bus guy to me
judge
took it away from me get out of here
shatner might not be as well known for
his comedic roles but a role he is known
for playing
captain james t kirk on star trek a show
he claimed to have never watched what
the devil is
all about but during our interview he
debunked that so why not play ryan
reynolds and live tweet an episode
it's not true that i haven't seen any
i've okay or
very few and uh and
you know that's enough
[Laughter]
while we hold our collective breath for
that shatner is busy cementing his
legacy in a very star trek way
so story files shot me for five days
doing interview
putting in an artificial intelligence
shooting me with
about 15 cameras all around so that i
was in 3d there's going to be a 3d
hologram of me with artificial
intelligence you'll have a button
press a button and i will answer a
question like you're answering asking me
now
listen fed with artificial intelligence
for five days of interviews
will answer you might even be able to
ask it about his friendship with the
late christopher plummer
you recently posted a picture of
christopher plummer and it really just
took a moment for me to just sit there
and kind of
reflect on the fact that you guys have
been friends for years and years and
years we
realized that we grew up together in
montreal he was
two or three years older than us and
that made a difference when you're
15 16 17 but he went on to be a
professional actress so it turned out i
was following
through to the mountain play house of
montreal to ottawa to the
canadian repertory the crt and then on
to stratfor
i followed him like i was a year behind
him so when i got to understudy him it
was like
natural because i was always one step or
two behind
yeah but he was a lovely man i admired
and respected it